e
o que é isso é o Veda aê
é exatamente isso que você está
escutando bem vídeo novo todos os dias
de Abril tá começando por hoje acabei de
chegar aqui na minha casa Fortaleza onde
nós vamos ser uma temporada de shows
aqui em Fortaleza todos de quase todos
os dias da semana e vai ter um vídeo por
dia
essa casa aqui a minha casa de Fortaleza
Olha isso é meu quarto aqui olha o meu
quartinho essa casa que é minha pode
chapeleiro porque eu tenho muito tempo
ele foi feito pela Priscila desde quando
eu morava em Sobral Ceará falta caminhão
bonitinha bom é isso não é vídeo novo
todos os dias de Abril mas para que dê
certo e dure até o fim Realmente eu
preciso que vocês me ajudem eu preciso
que vocês cliquem mostrei para saber se
vocês curtiram o episódio gostado vai
comentar alguma coisa assim faz isso vai
em tal lugar ou essa parte foi mas só
que eu poder entender porque eu tenho
que saber o que eu tenho que fazer um
mês inteiro foi que eu fazer coisas
diferentes todo dia ninguém quer a vida
tão legal 30 dias cada um é diferente o
dia do outro todos vou ter que fazer uma
vai Oi
aqui é a sala
[Música]
bom
estar com vocês que eu estou fazendo
agora estudando
e
quando vocês vão casar comigo se eu
fizer assim se inscrever e
e
[Música]
no show novo em um número eu estou
utilizando a papel de Orquestra eu tô
aprendendo a ser Maestro saber como é
que ele faz né para dominar a tua terra
E aí
[Música]
o e opa
o trabalho se agora um
fazer
a roupinha dele gostoso Ai que gostoso
o pit bull mãe as orelhinhas é a lilou
acompanhar muita vídeo dinheiro não dá
meu
é muito menininho
como é que tá aí
[Música]
Oi e o japonês
Bom dia nosso second
bom dia
olha só a gente que legal agora a gente
vai colocar fé
ai ai ai ai
galera
e
eu quero que vocês
e nem seus likes porque amanhã nesse
mesmo horário tem mais vídeo novo tá bom
[Música]
se
você a frente da casa é bonita e
G1 a man
se ele for
comprar onde menos
segundo informação mesmo momento doendo
correndo correndo correndo
[Música]
se eu tiver alguém levando um bicho não
é nem Fortaleza CE
e eu não é nem o dirigidor meu
passageiro ele é um do Milho eu
sou assim um show daqui a três horas tô
comprando remédio agora vai dar certo
obrigado Juninho novo né
Sem colateral de remédio para gripe o
sono perfeito quem é que esteja dormindo
agora eu encontro Serra Azul i
Olá tudo é Bru vão
sou eu vou para Cancun
etiele mada
ouvir que a Barbie é
e
eu preciso de uma pequeno
ai meu deus do céu e
[Música]
E aí
E olha que bota o
contador gente faz um saude de três do
show E aí nessa para nós é
O
que é
eu
volto gás de novo é
a tomar qualquer um minuto você vai
fazer três aulas de doce 3012 3112 tem
reta não mas tudo que é só usar uma
viada lá
E aí
E
aí
sim tá bom ó
um dois três quatro cinco seis
livros telespectador que a tecla até e
tudo mais
segurança também a
o melhor a fazer tudo
saiu bem
E aí
um
ponto baixo isso mesmo
beleza ela apoio é isso não
tivesse alguma assim machuca levando eu
vou dar ele ficou reto já faz assim ó
E aí
Ah
tá com capacete com a sentir é bom viu
uma vizinha legal mas não tenho só uma
professora menos 22 é mais
Comecei fazer
pegar isso aí eu gostei porque muitos
cara de box por exemplo perde muito
tempo tentando tirar o cara na cara mas
não rápido o cara que é o melhor do
mundo ele não tem pontos O segundo
melhor do mundo Pô acho que é fácil eu
tô até com o primeiro é fácil nossa
segunda não aí eu pego a senhora faz ele
pode ficar só na barriga e eles tem nada
não aguenta ficar todo mundo espera
volta na barriga e
E aí
e
eu quero
Oi
ok certo amor sempre pois é certo que
você perguntei ter mascote e a barriga
muito forte o bicho chega sabe o que
consigo nem mexer ali só olhar não foi
preparado aqui naquela [ __ ] entendeu
que eu morder você fez nada que eu
queria fazer nada tá prendendo aí
galerinha eu vou tomar um banho que eu
tenho um show hoje em Fortaleza mais
isso vocês só vão ver no blog de amanhã
porque tem vídeo todos os dias durante o
mês de abril Tá bom então se você gostou
dessa novidade clique em gostei para
você ser notificado vídeo que sair
amanhã eu quero que você comente aqui
embaixo que que você achou qual parte
que legal o que que interessante ver da
minha vida que eu também não sei que eu
mostro para vocês um
eu
achei um cobertor
que me deu o
amor
tempo mim
chega e pode estar
estou com ciúme Rei falar
mais
[Música]
não é
bom então tchau tchau clique em gostei
Espero que você tenha gostado de saber
um pouquinho da minha vida e você vai
fazer para saber muito mais durante mais
de 30 dias espero que vocês agora
estamos junto valeu e encher e for pick